المعارك في السودان لليوم السادس على
التوالي وتتركز في ولايه الخرطوم وفي
مدينه فاشر الواقعه غربيه البلاد في
العاصمه تتركز المعارك في محيط القصر
الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه للجيش
باستعمال الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه كما
امتدت الاشتباكات الى مناطق في مدينه ام
درمان اعنفها في منطقه المربعات واللاسلكي
جنوبي المدينه الاشتباكات على الارض في
ولايه الخرطوم تزامنت مع قصف للجيش
السوداني قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره انه
سادف رتلان لقوات الدعم السريع مدينه
الفاشر في ولايه شمال دارفور الواقعه
غربيه السودان شهدت معارك وصفت بالعنيفه
بين الدعم والجيش بشتى انواع الاسلحه في
ولايه شمال كردفان اكد مراسل جزيلا اندلاع
اشتباكات في مدينه الاوبيض الجنوبيه
البلاد